[Musique]
oui
c'est affreux tu ne peux pas décrire ce que tu
vois
les corps sur la route les morts
l'odeur de la mort vers
minuit ou 1h du matin
on commence à savoir
que 10 pour cent de ces pompiers
était mort
et l'opération de recherche
a commencé, cela fait environ
15 ou 20 jours jusqu'à ce que nous ayons trouvé
tous les martyrs des pompiers mais nous ne
les trouvons pas, nous trouvons la paix
d'eux
car ab car août est
rare sur terre à
Beyrouth oh mon dieu
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
euh, je dois savoir du point de vue
politique, de l'avocat, de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui,
où dans ce hangar,
pourquoi notre équipe est partie, nous sommes morts
pour avoir aidé les gens mais nous ne mourons pas pour
rien
[  Musique]
étrangère à
toi